hello everyone i'm haiku from sinhala
university today i'm going to introduce
our work embeddings and labeling schemes
for a star
this is a joint work with talia eden
from boston university and mit and
future indig from mit
this style is a classical and popular
algorithm for patch funding and has been
used for
use in robotics and game solving since
1960s
although a star has good improvement
performance there are few studies on its
running time analysis
estar search use a heuristic function to
estimate the distance from one vertex to
the destination the quality of this
heuristic function directly determines
the performance of a stock
traditionally heuristics are chosen by
experts based on the properties of the
underlying problems
recently there is a trend to use machine
learning to learn those heuristic
functions
we try to understand the relationship
between the heuristic function and a
stars running time
first before starting our results
we want to formalize the procedure of
exam algorithm and some properties of a
stock this sends us to the code on this
page
a star starts with a set capital s which
only contains the source vertex s
at this time a star expands a vertex u
with the minimum estimated distance
which is calculated by the distance from
s to udu plus hut which is a relative
function then the new vertex u is added
to the set s
and uses to update all the other
vertices uh distance
this process ended or ends when
definition t is contained in s
let's go through a toy example for a
star algorithm this is a graph
consisting of six vertices
we want to query the distance from
vertex a to f
black numbers are x waves and the blue
label above above vertices are the
estimated distance lower bound from
itself to the destination f
in the beginning in ground zero it
starts start with capital s equals eight
either the single
vertex
in round one the first word has to be
expanded is b because the distance from
a to b one plus the estimated distance
outbound from b to s equals 2 which is
the smallest smallest amount of
remaining vertices
in round 2 the next one to scan is
vertex c
the vertex e gets again
and finally vertex s is added to the set
if we do a comparison between a star and
the data extra which always scan the
vertex with the smallest distance to the
start point first here let's have d is
not scanned even though it is near the
south because the heuristic estimates d
to be far away from f
however vertex b not on the shortest
path from a to f scan a tube because
it's as many distance to the destination
is too loose
we think it's a one run to scan its
wrong vertex
from this example we can observe that
the quality of the estimated distance
lower bound decides the running time of
a star
in this page we introduced two
propositions for a stock consistent
resist and skin condition
throughout our analysis
we only focus on those consistent
heuristics
because according to heart at all 1968
consistently raises guarantee that the
estimated distance crossing a fixed
vertex u d u plus xu t is monotonically
increasing with time
only under this situation we are
confident that stopping a star when the
destination is found won't miss any any
unknown shot its path
therefore consistently related guarantee
a star algorithm's correctness
and we only consider a star's efficiency
when its correctness is guaranteed
the second one we consider here is its
scan condition also provided by heart
attack 1968
using consistence of releases
so one classic property here we say is
that one vertex u will be scanned by a
star in other words will be added to set
s before termination
if the distance from s to u plus uh plus
x u t the humidity function is smaller
than the distance from s to t
if the equality strictly holds then you
must be scanned no matter no matter
other conditions if this becomes of
equality then whether you will be
scanned depends on the type breaking
rule if if the inequality is false then
you won't be scanned by a star no matter
which category is used the importance of
typewriter will show up in the later
parts of our slide so we can ignore it
for now
the method for each star we consider
here is called
additive overhead on average the
definition 1.1
before giving the statement of
percentage 1.1 we first give two
notations
for graph g capital a capital p as t
denotes the set of vertices on the
shortest path between f to t
and the s h as t is the set of scanned
vertices
um for also inquiry as to t using
horizontal x x
here is an example for these two
notations uh this is a picture in the in
the last slide
and
in this example we'll correlate the
distance from a to f and p a s equals a
you say yes and the sas
has the additional vertex b here which
is scanned by a star but not on the
shortest test
and now we are able to describe our
definite 1.1
this characteristic h has additive
overhead c on average if for random
chosen pair of vertices a star scan c
additional vertices than the minimum
possible number of vertices
note that our metric only takes into
account the size of set capital s but
not the time spent by the whole
algorithm here are some advantages for
our metrics for example this is a
machine independent quantity and doesn't
depend on the data structure used to
optimize the algorithm
also this metric only depends on the
graph and heuristics
before stating our results we need to we
still need to give some restrictions on
the type of heuristic functions we
consider
the main heuristic functions we consider
here are named non-heuristics and
neighboring basics we think their
generality can cover most of the
commonly used heritage functions
we first said we first introduce our
definition for non-hyperbolicity see
definition 1.3 we first design a
magnetic part
projecting each vertex to a point in a
d-dimensional space or a
maximum vector and then use the lp knob
between two vertices as the estimated
distance lower bound to be our relative
function
another heuristic we consider is
labeling heuristics in definition 1.4
we first design an embedding f
projecting each vertex to a vector in a
dimensional space with dimension a
addition additionally we allow the next
function c to be arbitrary trojan
in temperature 1.4 we restrict
one coordinate to take value from from
an entry from 0 to c
we have this definite we have this
restriction because otherwise even one
coordinate can memorize infinite amount
of information
the difference between non-humanistic
and laboring heuristic is that
non-heuristic has no requirement on the
position of each dimension and requires
that the function h could be a lp-norm
function while labeling heuristics
supports arbitrary function g but
require that each dimension can only
take a value from 0 to capital c
we have another definite definition for
basics it's called becomes basic
actually because heuristic is a special
case for of l infinity non-pervasive but
we restrict our pi to take this specific
function which will be used later in the
proof of our overbought results
this page is a table summarizing our
main results our results provide lower
bounds for non-heuristics and labeling
heuristics and also upper bounds for our
infinity non-heuristic and labeling
basics in the remaining of my
presentation i will elaborate on this
result table
we first look at zero 1.6 here which is
the lower bound result for lp
non-previously
uh
not that's the for certain 1.6 the loss
also works for p equals infinity case
but because it is too loose
if the dimension is invalid dimension d
now it is too loose if p equals infinity
and will and can be covered by the next
theorem so we can ignore the second case
for now
this theorem says that we can construct
a vertex graph
if the embedding dimension d is smaller
than n over log n
then installers get omega n vertices on
average
here m l p naught l previously covers
the classical manhattan norm and the
euclidean known this is a quite quite
strong lower bound because it says that
it starts performance is almost no
better than that extra except a constant
factor
the proof idea for this theorem is that
under lp norm
for a vertex in a space with dimensions
smaller than n it is impossible to form
a equilateral set
therefore there must if there is one
distorted pair if the dimension is not
high enough a the graph below
but we left c1 c2 to c4 be the
equilateral set but in the inverting
embedding space they cannot be
equilateral and there must be one
distorted pair
we can actually
amplify the penalty which is the running
time of a star by constructing many
auxiliary vertices connecting to them
this one and the later this one
then we argue that it starts when
calling those pair of vertices uh for
example this one and this one
whose surface path across the defaulted
pair in the center in the center will
suffer from very high a running time
next we talk about talk about theorem
1.7 on the lower bound for our
infinitive non-heuristic
this is that we can construct a weighted
and vertex graph whose maximum shortest
path consists of constant number of
hopes such that if a star characteristic
uses a infinitive norm in an evangelical
space of dimension d smaller than n to
the power of alpha itself will scan
omega n to the power of y minus alpha
vertices on average here alpha is an
arbitrary chosen parameter between 0 and
1.
additionally our constructed instance in
this theorem can be transformed into
grades if alpha is smaller than 0.5
because the result of zero on
3.4
here
next case
output idea for this theorem consists of
three parts a special property for
infinitive norm we use here is that the
infinite number between two
vectors depends on only one coordinate
if we call certain coordinates crucial
for this pair of vertices then in the
invalid space each dimension can only
contain a limited number of those
crucial coordinates
or some or some of some
predictions will appear if they are
there are too many crucial coordinates
occupying the same dimension orbit
therefore
therefore in this graph we have a
central click a1 to am
by carefully setting the parameter w we
can prove that at least one distorted
vertex pair exists if the dimension is
not high enough then we can construct
some auxiliary vertices to amplify the
parentheses like here those
b's
okay
uh then we look at certain 1.8 the lower
bound result for library heuristics
similarly 71.8 can also be transformed
into a great graph version for zero 3.9
with additional assumptions additional
requirements that alpha is smaller than
0.5
student 1.8 says that
this is that we can construct a weighted
vertex graph whose maximum shortest path
consists of
constant number of hopes and if a star
use labeling heuristics
uh
er small with with length l smaller than
n to the power of alpha it's our scale
at least omega n to the power of y minus
alpha vertices there r by is an
arbitrary parameter between 0 and 2 1.
the result is similar to the last zero
the ground constructed here is the same
with the last theorem uh this instance
but with a different proof idea the
proof idea here is different from
previous one because of all for labor
heuristics we do not know any
information about the function g rather
than the non-hypothesis therefore the
strategy we use here is that we reduce
memorizing a set of random numbers to
finding the shortest path and then we
apply the indexing communication
complexity to prove our theorems
so now we turn our attention to upper
bound results zero one point ten and one
point two
one here 1.10 says that if a star can
actually break ties then because 6 with
beacon set n to the power of alpha
enjoys average additive overhang n to
the power of 1 minus alpha
the proof is very easy
a randomly selected beacon cell can
enjoy this result the online analysis is
that if we check a star scan condition
one vertex not lying on the surface path
will be scanned if the distance lower
bound produced by it is better than all
of those beacons estimation
which
will intuitively happen with probability
inverse proportional to the size of the
concept
one thing i want to explain here is that
our assumption on arbitrarily type
rating
recall a star starts restore scan
condition a dso plus hot is smaller than
dst
if the equality becomes an equality
without previously that this vertex
yield may or may not be scanned by a
stock
and this is the place where typewriters
show up especially for speaker b6 ties
are quite common and the power deal will
deal with this ties can influence the
final performance to a large extent
for certain 1.10 we use an assumption to
get rid of all the equalities and only
take into account those vertices must be
scanned
in our next theorem 1.12 it says that if
we replace the arbitrarily typewriting
assumption with a milder
uniqueness status path assumption we can
construct a listing heuristics
automatically breaking all the types and
enjoy additive overheads and to the
power of one minus alpha still using
embedding lengths are smaller than n to
the power of alpha actually our kashmaki
label chemistry can guarantee that no
type exists in a star's vertex lighting
process
the proof idea is that to break ties we
add an infinitely small lens to those
not strictly tight estimated distance
lower bounds to do this we only need to
identify whether a pair of vertices
while the false health vertices the
estimated distance is exactly the true
distance if all the shortest paths are
unique this size class can be easily
done by including the euler tool there
are two of the thirties past three
rooted at each beacon and
then check the location of two vertices
on the certain path tree
the encoding will only
increase the embedding layers by a
constant factor
at last let's return to the summary
table they have zero lower bound
1.6
uh gives omega n lower bounds which is
relatively strong there are boundaries
are infinity known here
and the
zero 1.8 which is little error bound for
living heuristics they are similar they
both say that as like the d or l which
is a complex measure of the embedding
smaller than
o and to the power of alpha the a star
will
suffer from omega n to the power of one
minus r square running time
we also give matching upper bounds in
zero 1.10 and 1.2
in conclusion we theoretically studied
the performance of a star algorithm by
analyzing the relationship between the
complexity of pervasive function and the
number of vertices gained for
non-heuristic and living heuristics
covering the most commonly used type of
heuristics we provide matching lower
bound and occupant results our lower
bound results are simple enough to be
transformed into greater graphs with
some original parameter constraint and
thus useful for empirical studies
and that's all my presentation thank you